oh
welcome to the thursday afternoon just
before
friday monday morning podcast i
hope all you [__] are well
i'm lying here in my office doing this
[__]
because i decided to start a [__]
podcast
on thursdays
um how are you everybody what's going on
man
what's going on um it's christmas eve oh
it's the holiday
season scooby dooby doo um
i hope all you guys have a very merry
christmas i hope you enjoyed your
kwanzaa
jewish people hope you got your chinese
food lined up for tomorrow
my wife she decided that you know we
were going to order a christmas dinner
right because what would women be doing
if they weren't spending [__] money
right
[Music]
you know it's like or we could just cook
the [__] meat we have in the freezer
no i just was kind of in the mood so she
goes
in orders waters the only thing that is
honest around here is bulls
um frank um
so she orders these this [__]
christmas meal
so they had the the christian
meal and then they had the jewish meal
but all the christian meals were gone so
now we're having a jewish meal we're
having chinese food
on christmas so i guess you know i don't
know what
i guess i've been in hollywood too long
[Laughter]
[Music]
so we're gonna see jewish people we're
gonna see what this is all about i'm
kind of excited about it
you know you know you gotta love chinese
food right you eat it and 10 minutes
later you're hungry again you go back
and eat it again you're hungry again you
know why because there's no nutrition in
it
all right there's no nutrition in it the
the chinese food in china has nutrition
but chinese food here
does not i feel unless defeating it to
other chinese people
because hey man they're trying to take
us out you know the whole china virus
and the chinese food doesn't fill you up
poisons you i'm telling you man it's a
thing
i'm [__] with you i was talking to a
buddy of mine who just
who he went where he went he went he
went hey by the way any chinese people
listening out here live in los angeles
this is what i want to know where do you
get where do you go to get your food
okay and if you don't want to tell me
because you don't want to ruin it
by having some orange ginger cut like me
showing up to your spot i
i totally respect that all right but if
you're a little more open
a little more progressive and you want
to tell me where it is i would also
why don't you give me your third choice
you don't have to give me your first
choice
all right just just help a round eye out
over here
um eddie who the [__] was i talking
about
um oh one of my buddies
let me tell you let me tell you remember
when i was totally if you're a longtime
fan of this remember when i was really
into conspiracy theory
i still believe all of that [__] i just
don't pay attention to it anymore
i get it i get it it's it's illegal for
me to start a ponzi scheme but the
federal reserve
that's okay we can protect that with
you know dead babies and all kinds of
other they don't give a [__]
right i get all of that okay i get
that the pharmaceutical companies right
now they're not all about trying to cure
people
okay i think the people working on it
are but the people up the top the green
people
all right the green people up there and
i don't mean they're into the
environment
all right they're in the dollars to roll
up
snort a [__] line out of some
hooker's ass that's what they're into
that's what they're into all right while
they wear some sort of shirt with their
[__] initials sewed into the cuff
i'm talking about those [__] all right
they want to be the ones that have it
they want to be the only ones that have
it and they want to buy i guarantee you
they want to charge out the [__] ass
for it
this is the big thing they're not trying
to save people's lives they are trying
to make
a [__] load of money so they can blow
lines
out of some hooker's ass okay and you
think if you think she's getting the
vaccine after she lets them do that yeah
you got another thing coming
all right um so anyways my buddy is
real okay i'm into all of that [__] i
believe all of that [__] but i don't
torture people with it
okay i i just accepted that human beings
we are imperfect myself is at the top of
that list
and we're doing the best we can all
right
and the reality is is most people can't
keep secrets
can't keep their [__] yap shut so the
government has to have their secrets
all right and you know you got
sociopaths in every country usually in
positions of power and they don't give a
[__]
about other human beings so you know
it's it's a dirty game
it's like the nba in the [__] 90s
when the knicks had that [__] you
know the broad street bully team which i
loved
i loved back in the day where you had to
be a man to dunk a basketball in the nba
yet you had to go into the trees
it was like predator i see him over
there in them trees shaving your [__]
head
with the dry razor that was that was the
nba that i grew up on
okay not this [__] hanging out on a
yacht with all the stars around the
league and you guys all [__] jump on
the same team like those
and you know when you come out they
introduce you like those chicks at
[__] radio city music hall and then
you go out and you trounce the [__]
league because nobody has any talent
left
i'm not talking about that league that's
not the league i'm talking about i'm
talking about
the nba right up until they flipped out
because the indiana pacers beat the [__]
out of some people in the crowd
that deserved an ass kicking all right
and those white people who sat in that
[__] crowd and who accidentally got
punched
have a lot of [__] nerve getting
upset with who punched him
considering they live in that [__]
state and they look the other way with
all those [__] clan members
all right so somebody was gonna have to
take a [__] knuckle sandwich for it
all right
and that's what you get for bumping up
your seats do you imagine if that
happened that night you know that when
they do that when some sad sack they
take them from the upper deck
we're gonna bring it down courtside
right they're like oh my god stuff like
this
never happens to me there is a santa
claus and then they bring them all the
way down
and next thing you know uh met a world
peace
he's [__] swinging it you goddamn
melon
i mean that that's when the league was
exciting
okay and i got to tell you something all
the bitching that people did at the same
time
okay if you [__]
if you're [__] into wrestling
you gotta love that they went into the
crowd if you like hockey you gotta love
that thing i know this is old [__]
speaking of which i watch the [__]
i'll talk about my conspiracy theory
friend here in a minute
i watched the uh the celtics bucks game
great game
absolutely atrocious call at the end of
the game thank god for [__]
instant replay it was just like jesus
christ they got another mobbed up ref
out here the [__] are you talking about
here
um plus they had the celtics getting
four you know what i mean and i was just
like i need this game to end in
regulation right now
all right that's what the [__] i need i
i this if this goes in overtime i
got a feeling i'm gonna lose this bet
right so i had the celtics
um so anyway
um the [__] was i talking about i was
talking about bringing people down
i literally just i'd have to go back and
listen what the [__] was i just talking
about god damn it
all right i hate when people do this to
me especially on radio shows and you
can't [__] call in
remind me and i'll finish where the [__]
was i going with that
he's talking about the nba
coffee used to be predator sansa coming
down from the upper deck
ah [__] guys it's gone i don't want to
tell you
it's just [__] gone i was watching
that game
i want a [__] bread yeah it's gone
just like that
just like that you know just like your
friend when you were a kid
you know you played every day and then
just one day a moving van showed up and
you never saw him again and it was the
70s and your parents never
never let you deal with that emotion
so years later you know you're sitting
on some busted leather
couch in a [__] green room and some
chucklehead
waiting to do a third show on a saturday
night in front of 18 people
trying to figure out how the [__] he
ended up there
um sorry i'll remember later right
so my conspiracy theory friend was
texting me and he was showing me this
[__] article
about you know all the ways the
government has [__] this thing up and
you know
and [__] over the small businessman
and all this type of [__]
and i'm just like yeah no yeah i know
that they they could have done a better
job we all could have done a better job
including people who don't wear masks
and just stand six feet apart from
people i don't think that's such a big
ask when you get a flat screen tv and
your clothes are all made in a sweatshop
by crying children i think you can put
on a [__] mask and just
and he writes back masks don't work
and i just write all right buddy good
night i'll talk to you later because i
know i don't want to argue with people
about this [__] and then he goes
this whole thing was perfectly set off
by
china and i'll get something dude that's
what's wrong with the [__] internet
right there okay somebody needs to
regulate this [__]
because this guy is absolutely convinced
you go on a [__] laptop and you watch
a video and they put music underneath it
people just [__] believe it
they believe every [__] goddamn thing
that they're looking at and it's like
you got [__] people now they think
the [__] world is flat
it's a bunch of stupid [__] going to
get in a boat and sail
not sail what do you call it when you
[__] turn on the motor
cruise a [__] cruise
down to antarctica to go look at the
[__] ice wall they think there's an
ice wall there
there's a wall of ice holding back the
oceans of the world
um but the government that he's like
what
is what is
the benefit of people thinking it's
round when it's really flat
what what does anybody gain out of that
or do they just want to be right
i don't know what it is but anyway like
this [__] guy
is not a doctor and he doesn't work for
the cia so it's like dude i'm not
listening to you okay
now if you if you tell me i got a friend
who works in the cia
and he's telling me that china started
this [__] on purpose
then i got to sit there and i got to
read your body language is this guy just
saying this [__] so i'll believe it
or does he really have a friend and how
good is that
agent that not only did he spill the
beans of this
jerk off that he he spilled the beans to
some jerk-off who can't keep his [__]
mouth shut
what if this was a test of this guy
and he just failed it and i'm gonna get
whacked with him
because i'm sitting here at a [__]
taco stand as he's telling me this [__]
so i just say good night i don't i don't
want to be i don't want to be a part of
i don't be privy
to any of that [__] um
so anyway like i said the goddamn
vaccine is coming
all right i will take it and if i no
longer make fun of the standing
president which i'm gonna have a ball
with joe biden i had a great time with
donald trump i had a great time with
[__]
obama george bush
and clinton i mean that was just
back-to-back comedy gold
you know and then i don't know
obama was all right his wife was funnier
and then uh
and trump was just i mean the guy was
just he was prolific
[__] prolific and then i got a
feeling joe biden
in this nitwit that he's with is gonna
be even better
um that's what i'm thinking uh anyway
let me plow ahead here um so
for my uh my daughter has been asking
for a bicycle
for christmas all right and there's no
way she's not getting one all right if
she
for one okay i get i got to do it right
daddy's little girl okay it's not this
is this is how i look at
parenting all right with my son it's
gonna be my job to say no i can't expect
my wife to say no
that's how it works right and if there's
a daughter
like the mom's got to be the back it's
always good cop bad cop all right
i'm good cop with my daughter i'm going
to be bad cop with my son
and vice versa somebody's got to put
their foot down and then the other
person kind of has to back
him but like just not be the one not be
the bearer of bad news
so anyway my daughter asked for this
bike right
she wants a green bicycle so i'm like oh
that's great i got a green car this is
great i'll get her the bicycle
so i'm scouring the internet in other
words i i googled for about [__]
three minutes and i find this great vice
bicycle i put the [__] thing together
and about three days ago i'm like holy
[__] i forgot i got to go buy training
wheels to put it on this [__] thing
and do you know that this goddamn bike
i i didn't just buy a bike i bought into
an ideology
and their ideology is that training
wheels hold
the kid back which is amazing because
when i was a kid
everybody had training wheels and we all
learned how to ride a bike
you know what i mean there was
absolutely
nothing wrong with it right
and these guys are women who ever have
this [__] bike
company are so adamant about the fact
that you're not gonna put training
wheels on this bike they invented a
[__] screw
that i don't even know what the [__]
goddamn [__] sorry
[__] tool you need to take that
[__] thing off you cannot
they made it that it was impossible one
guy
on [__] amazon figured out some
macgyver [__]
and he was describing all the [__] he
bought at the hardware i didn't like
start
googling you know i mean i'm eating
potatoes at the [__] hardware store
you know not
bold screw washer extension cord
hammer i don't go deep i'm not in those
[__]
i don't go in the pro aisles of the
hardware store you know with this
[__]
that pc [__] i'm gonna say pcp pcv
piping and all of that [__] you know you
look down the aisle and it just looks
like everybody there was underneath the
house for the last 10 years
those guys no no
those guys i'm not those guys right so i
didn't know what half of that [__] was
so um i was so [__] goddamn this you
know what this [__] is the fact that
they that you know they they should just
say listen
we advise that you don't put training
wheels and give you options the fact
that they're like no
you can't with this bike and the fact
that it's not blazed across their
[__] website
before you buy this bike just to let you
[__] know because now
let me she's going to fall down she's
going to need [__]
knee pads elbow pads
it's just the [__] that's going through
my head as a
as a parent it's going to knock her
[__] teeth out
i got to run alongside this goddamn
thing the fact that they don't even give
you a
[__] option with this goddamn bite
you know what i you know what it's been
starting to say my white you know what
that's man bun [__] there's there's a
[__] line
in the sand a lot of people think it's
like music auto-tune it isn't
the man bun when it became acceptable
that a guy
walked around you know with with his
hair done up like that like some chick
after she banged you know some [__]
dude she was going down to get a coffee
the fact that a guy could go to work
dressed like that
with this scraggly [__] beard where
his mustache didn't connect to the beard
and his stupid-ass [__] man bun
like that that was a change okay the
warning
was dressed down fridays and we started
with that [__]
and now we've ended up with guys with
man buns now i know man buns are out it
kind of seemed like they went away
you know but you know it
there's definitely there's like it's
like jesus that there's before him and
then after him
you know before him there were wars and
after him there were way more
[Music]
i don't know what i'm saying here all
right the celtics got the brooklyn nets
next by the way i'm just going to give
into this [__] ideology because these
[__]
[__] they're forcing on him and i would
call him up right but i know goddamn
mostly well it's on our website
it's on our website where what did i
have to click on
you [__] douche bags all i saw was
bicycles
ugh that's what i get for waiting 90
years to have a kid all right
there's no training wheels anymore it
inhibits there blah blah
dude this is an experiment and you're
using my kid as a goddamn
guinea pig so i don't know i talked to a
buddy of mine who's a younger dad and he
told me that he taught his kid that way
so i kind of all right all right all
right maybe i'm stuck in my own ways
maybe i'm doing the old guy yeah this
isn't music maybe this is a better
[__] way but
i don't know so now i got to take the
[__] pedals off and turn it into a
balance bike
first i guess
i guess that makes sense it kind of
makes sense
i don't know i just wanted to ride bikes
with their own [__] christmas that's
what i wanted to do
i didn't want to have to go out there
and worry that she was going to knock
her [__] teeth out
all right anyway sorry i'm glad i got
that off my chest i'm sorry you had to
hear it
you know i'll send you a little basket
of [__] treats how about that
um all right here's a question i have
because celtics are playing the brooklyn
nets who kicked our [__] ass
about a week ago um here's my question
about brooklyn net fans
uh were you new jersey net fans first
then i get it
i just don't understand the brooklyn fan
that was a fan of the new york knicks
first of all
a legendary squad even though they
haven't won in a long time they've gone
through
but still new york and basketball
they play at madison square garden
they're called the knicks
new york knicks i mean that is just one
of the badass
like city with with name of team
that you can have out there the knicks
some [__] man [__] right
then you get the nets that kind of
sounds like the knicks but it isn't
it was an aba team you know i will say
they did have julia serving right
he's with the kentucky colonels and then
i think they became the new jersey nets
i don't [__] know
but i just want to know how you as a
brooklyn
new york knick fan growing up
okay and you lived and died and all of
that [__] you have
all of that emotion invested in the new
york knicks because someday they're
going to win a championship
and i'm telling you you're going to see
grown men crying
right and you just walk away from that
because they stick a team in brooklyn
and you live in brooklyn i just don't
[__] get it
um if i worked for the nba i would say
this is not gonna work
new york is the knicks
okay brooklyn they they played out there
where jimmy hoffa's buried
all right what are we doing here so tell
me that fascinates me
because i've never really talked to a
sports fan about that
people that like just switch teams
like um i got a buddy of mine long time
cleveland brown fan he was heartbroken a
friend of his just couldn't take it
anymore
and said [__] it and he became a
steelers fan
he didn't say [__] it i'll root for the
rams i'll go
he went with their rival i mean it's
like a bruins fan becoming a canadians
fan or
you know laker fan becoming a celtics
fan however you want to do the math
just fascinates me so
it wasn't like the nets were some big
rival but it's just
i'm just really curious
like i know the knicks
it's been they've been asking a lot of
you to be a [__] fan
for a while but um
it is the best like exp i think fan
experience
it's the perfect to go to a game it's
the perfect combination
of it's just new york like everybody's
there
and then you still have the la like
laker thing where you got some famous
people sitting courtside
and it's the garden where led zeppelin
played
frank sinatra did his comeback thing
it's it's all these [__] ali fought
there
how you just say [__] that
and you go to the brooklyn nets where
their goddamn arena
they got like a car sitting out like the
one they have like a car
sitting where like all these great seats
should be
it looks like you're driving by a
dealership when you look at it quickly
it just fascinates me i'm just curious
about that [__]
um how you went from a nick to a
brooklyn net fan
answer although it's looking pretty good
as far as your happiness right now but i
was just
what did you do with all your old knicks
gear did you just throw it out
your skywalker jersey kenny skywalker
you patrick ewing larry johnson
anthony mason um all right let's talk uh
let's talk turkey here going to do a
little [__] advertising all right
policy genius every
everybody you know the holiday season
dooby dooby doo
sure knows how to lighten your wallet
god is not the [__] truth
uh for many families december is one of
the most expensive months of the year
doesn't have to be but for some dumb
reason it is right not to mention the
busiest
if you need life insurance but don't
want
to deal with the hassle or expense try
policy genius it combines a cutting edge
insurance marketplace
with help from licensing experts to save
you time
and money right now you could save up to
50 percent off
or more by using policy genius to
compare life
insurance when you're shopping for a
policy that could last more than a
decade
those savings really start to add up
here's how it works
first head to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare your
quotes from top insurers to find your
best price
policy genius will compare policies
starting as at as little as
one dollar a day
okay they're leaving no stone unturned
you might even be eligible to skip the
in-person medical exam
all right once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape
and the best part is that they work for
you not the insurance company so if you
hit
any speed bumps during the application
proc process
they'll take care of everything hey
what's going on over here
uh prudential's giving you a rough
[__] time hang on a second let me go
talk to this [__] guy
it wouldn't be great if they went over
they slapped slapped around one of those
pieces of [__] in a [__] cubicle
uh that kind of service has earned
policy genius a five-star rating across
over 1600 reviews
on trustpilot in google uh if you have
if you have loved ones who depend on
your income
don't go into 2021 without life
insurance go to policygenius.com and get
started
you could save 50 or more by comparing
quotes and start the new year
with one less thing to worry about
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right oh look who's
here
simply safe you know i've been trying to
get one of these [__] things
i got to get simply safe i've been
meaning to do what i should say for a
person a buddy of mine
had his apartment broken into uh
everyone wants to keep their home and
family safe whether it's from
from a break-in a fire flooding or
medical emergency simply safe home
security delivers award-winning 24 7
protection
with simply safe you don't just get an
arsenal of cameras and sensors
you get the best professional monitors
in the business they've got your back
day and night
ready to send police fire emts when you
need them
straight to your door simply safe has an
arsenal of sensors and cameras that
protect every inch of your home
you can set it up yourself in 30 minutes
it's super easy
then simply say professionals can take
over monitoring your home 24 7
and ready to send help the moment
there's an alarm
plus with simply safe there's no
long-term contracts no hidden fees or
installation costs right now my
listeners get a free home security
camera
when you purchase a simply safe system
at simply safe.com hey can you do this
for somebody else i want to give
somebody one of these simply safe let me
know
uh you also get a 60-day risk-free trial
so there's nothing to lose visit simply
safe
s-i-m-p-l-i safe
dot com for your free security camera
today that's simply safe.com
oh look who it is it's [__] head
space man
[Music]
don't harsh the mellow man you know
life can be stressful i could use head
space after trying to put [__]
training wheels on that goddamn man bun
[__] over there
that's man bun [__] you know i'm you
guys if you listen to this podcast from
here or not because i don't want to
[__] have to explain myself
all right if i just say that's some man
bun [__] i don't want to hear it i don't
just
just know what i'm talking about all
right headspace
all right man bun [__] means you can't
play a guitar
but you can play a laptop all right
that's man bunch [__]
okay and just apply whatever the [__]
you want to that
all right headspace life can be
stressful even under normal
circumstances
2020 has challenged even the most
difficult times of life
you need stress relief that goes beyond
quick fixes that's head space man
next please mention a few of the talking
points below hey you know what it's
christmas headspace i'll [__] read
all of them
headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditation and an easy to use app
god damn it i need this [__] headspace
is the is the one and only hey if you
don't end up like me
go to [__] headspace how about that
headspace is the is the one and only
is one of the only sorry meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness
and meditation through clinically
validated research you know what's this
reminded me of
i want to [__] go out to the desert
and try that peyote [__]
and just see if i can get past some [__]
i think i'm finally ready to deal with
the fact that i might have a bad trip
you know that there might be too many
monsters between the [__] earlobes
there
uh so whatever the situation headspace
can really help you feel better
overwhelmed headspace has a three-minute
sos meditation for you isn't that great
in three minutes you'll feel better i
can't find a parking spot
you just put it in park for three
minutes you block out people
just block out people beeping behind you
just you know
you just address that it's happening but
just you don't have to react to it
and exhale all right need some
help falling asleep headspace has wind
down sessions their members swear by
and for parents headspace even has
morning meditations
you can do with your kids
what if you can get my kids to sit still
that'd be amazing headspace is a pro
what a great thing to teach a kid how to
meditate
wow talk about the inverse of my
childhood head spaces hey you know what
maybe i shouldn't do this maybe this is
some man bun [__]
i'm not saying for the parents but if i
tried it for the kids
now i'm doing it headspace is i've
curated
meditation headspace approach to
mindfulness can reduce stress improve
sleep boost focus
and increase your overall sense of well
being
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star
reviews and over 60 million downloads
they are crushing it
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice with
your with mindfulness that works for you
on your schedule anytime anywhere all
right so how do you get it you go to
headspace.com you deserve to feel
happier and headspace is meditation made
simple that's
slash headspace.com for a free one month
trial with access
to headspace's full library of
meditation for every situation
this is the best deal offered right now
to headspace.com
today all right hey by the way
all my latino listeners
i tried at torta the other day
remember when i was telling you i judged
i judged a mexican restaurant
on their burrito i judge a pizza
a pizzeria by their margarita pizza i
don't want you hiding behind your
[__]
uh your toppings that's like the guy
talking [__]
backing up in a bar joe derosa and all
his friends feeling
in the negative space um
so i'm going to say i i i judged
a mexican restaurant by the burrito and
then some
mexican kid wrote in and he said the
burrito
is the ultimate [__] gringo white guy
order
don't order that [__] and he had all of
these suggestions for all of this other
[__] one of the things i can remember
was the torta
so i went in there my broken french and
was
i said uh i was like
uh bonapremedi senorita
a torta play right so they got me one
they were like what kind of meat do you
want on that and i was like uh
i ordered the chicken right um
oh sorry uh
avec um no i ordered the chicken
and i got to tell you something i ate
that thing and it [__] sucked
it was a goddamn mayonnaise sandwich all
right mexicans relax
let me get to the end of this so now i
know
that that restaurant [__] stinks
okay i'm not coming down on the sandwich
i'm not coming down on the cuisine
i just threw the help
of a latino listener i now know that i
should not be going to that anymore
so thank you um and i am now in the
search
for somebody who knows how to make a
torta correctly torta
correctly and with that let's start this
come on let's let's [__] share some
information over here
all right let's share some information
over here i want to hear from chinese
people
where you're going to get your chinese
food in here in la
okay i want to hear from lesbians i want
to hear what you do to keep your
girlfriend
[__] from nagging at you all right
just whatever
whatever you got just [__] come at me
all right
if you guys want to learn some bald
ginger [__] just ask me some [__]
questions i have no problem answering
um speaking of answers
so i've been telling you i got a new
ride here as far as the the helicopters
that i'm
flying i got the uh the cadbury g2
and so the other day i was flying it
again
and you know i got the hang of it you
know because i was telling you the main
road
turns the opposite way so it changes
your your pedal inputs right
so i got that down to the point i got it
down
good enough i should say that um we
tried to do some auto rotations which is
you simulate engine failure
yada yada yada and i have to tell you
something i
the only way for me to describe what
it's like to do an auto rotation in the
cadbury g2
after coming from a robinson r22
is do you remember in ferris bueller's
day off when those guys took the far
the the parking attendants took the
ferrari out and remember when they went
over the hill and they were smiling
that's what it was like because the r22
which i [__] love that helicopter by
the way
i love that helicopter because if you
can hover in that thing if you can fly
that thing
if you can do auto rotations in that
thing it's only going to get easier from
what i've heard from other pilots
because you know i'm [__]
a weekend warrior but i will tell you
that was my experience going to the
cadbury g2
it was [__] amazing okay like i
the way that you just lock in i felt
like i was coming down and i was
i was floating on a cloud versus the 22
where i had to be like 10 knots faster
and i was dropping like a [__] stone
i now have a three-bladed fully
articulated main rotor system as opposed
to a
two-bladed semi-articulated whatever the
[__] you call it
and um i had finally gotten those
[__] things down in the 22
and now all my pedal inputs were
different you know collective down now
it's left
left pedal instead of right pedal and
but what i love is
is i always felt like in the r22 there
was like
a sliver of rpms that you could play
with where before you were too low and
the low rpm
horn would come on and then you'd go to
correct it and then then it would
[__] start to over speed and it
really took a high level of skill
or you know if you fly as not often as i
do it took a long time for me to [__]
and i do i've done a million of those
things
and i was really starting to feel it in
the 22 when you start to feel the rpms
coming up and
you almost don't have to listen to look
at the gauge you can just hear it
and you know i was catching them coming
up and i was really i really had it all
the way down my flare was nice
you know um
i kept [__] up the flare where i
would i pull the stick too far back and
you would balloon up
and then you're going to lose all your
inertia and your main rotor blade and
then you're going to
slam down on the ground probably blow
out your skids and [__] up your back
right which who wants to do that right
so i was finally getting that down so
anyways
i did like five of them and it was so
much easier
and it was so much slower i felt than
the 22
that like within four auto rotations we
moved on to the more advanced [__] that
i was doing with the 22
which is basically rather than picking
out a spot
you know when you first learn them you
just you're looking out and you're
looking at a spot that you're going to
glide down to we started doing the [__]
where
towards the end where you're over your
spot
so you you just let the thing drop
straight you bleed off all your forward
air speed and you just let it drop
and then you know you've lost all your
forward air speed which you're gonna
have to recover
and you had to judge it when you'd nose
it back down
you know you're almost like backing up
to get to the spot then you nose it over
regain your air speed and then do your
flare so it took me forever to get that
level on the 22
i did five auto rotations and my
instructor was go all right let's try it
like over the spot so i'm thinking of my
head like well we're already moving on
to advance our rotation this is [__]
cool as hell
so um very
very very very excited and uh i
shouldn't keep
i'm not coming down on robinson's
because they're [__] great
helicopters and every time i see an r22
anytime i look in the cockpit i just
smile i've had so many
so many great times in that [__]
thing but um
[Music]
i think most people in aviation you
start out and then you know they're the
low end things and then you move on to
something else
i couldn't be more [__] thrilled uh
with this thing so any pilots out there
considering
you know you know what you want to buy
definitely you know
or what you want to if you i don't know
i think you got to buy those things i
just lucked out with this
there's a deal here with the the people
i'm i
rent from got one um
but like if you're thinking about buying
one i mean i this is like free
advertising i cannot [__] tell you
like i love this helicopter so much i'm
trying to find
merch on the internet but then i'm like
am i gonna be that
dork on who shows up like this is my hat
cause this is the helicopter i fly
you know like they're sponsoring me with
my 250 hours
but um it was so
[__] it was just it just made my god
damn weak
um i am in love with that helicopter uh
i still love the robinsons and all that
[__] so i'm not trying to cause any
[__]
i'm just being honest i love those
helicopters and now i'm flying this one
and i love this one
even more and it's just [__] amazing
and it's great that it's out there
because i think it's going to make the
robinson's
robinsons even better um so there you go
that's the podcast sorry for the nerding
out with the uh
helicopter [__] there in the end um
that's it you guys
have yourselves a very merry little
christmas
um i will talk to you on monday i hope
all you guys stay
safe you don't do any dumb [__]
uh shout out to all the overworked
people in the hospitals
um kicking ass out there every day
that's it go [__] yourselves have a
great weekend you [__]
merry christmas and i'll talk to you on
[Music]
monday
uh
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
december 24th 2012.
and as you can see the way i stress
december 24th
that i am i am i am letting you guys
know that i realize that it's christmas
eve
okay i realized that therefore this has
to be a very special podcast
uh which it won't be but i'm just
letting you know that i know
that you feel that it should be special
shouldn't i have some sort of christmas
special going on here
singing you guys some holiday tunes
huh have ollie jolly christmas
oh it's the best time of the year
everybody is pretty cool except for that
douchey sister married
um there's always one right
there's always going to be that one
[__] guy
everybody's having a good time and then
this one [__] has to come in
moping around you know
who is it the chick with the substance
abuse problem
or the moody guy
i'd rather have the substance abuse
check around in the moody guy
the moody guy's the worst he comes in
right like the [__] antithesis of
mistletoe
you know he should have mistletoe on his
shoes
pointed the other direction like some
sort of devil reference
you know instead of hanging from the
heavens it's coming up from the [__]
floor
right kiss my [__] feet everybody
because you're gonna have to deal with
me and my mood because i'm not just
gonna have the decency to be miser
miserable over in the corner
i'm gonna [__] sit down right in
front of everybody and just sit there
sulking
you know and there'll be a couple of
[__] hardcore people who will see it
and they'll just roll their eyes but
there's always the
one douche the one chick who's a member
of the 4-h club
or whatever the hell it is that she does
bake sales
helps out with the church car wash
whatever the [__] she does but you know
she has to
what's matter what's matter
you look sad oh my god are you sad
she sees [__] sad every year watch
the language around the middle toe
karen don't [__] do this don't
every [__] year i don't care if their
kids are gonna hear it anyway
they're gonna hear it anyway
all right every year this douche comes
in
looking like [__] droopy dog and i'm
sick of it it's not my
fault his lights i don't care if he can
hear me
of course he's leaving of course he's
leaving you leaving you leave all where
you gonna go huh
kill yourself in a [__] rest area
um right it's one of those deals
every year there's that douche then
there's always the douche who has to try
and top everybody's stories
you know you could be sitting there with
the [__] astronaut
he'd somehow try to top or correct them
well actually i thought uh according to
uh
you know what i don't know a video game
some [__] astronaut video game that
douche played
he'd actually try to question a real ass
who even knows an astronaut at this
point aren't they all
dead did the people who were on the
space shuttle were they considered
astronauts because i
didn't consider them astronauts you're
not an astronaut if you're in a plane
okay and i know it's a big one
i know it's got rockets on it initially
all right but all i know
is that the astronauts that i grew up on
with
were [__] they were at the top of a
missile
that's what they did you didn't steer
that [__] thing i mean how they got
back they had a little capsule
i think you just leaned to one side you
kept rolling back towards the earth
hoping you'd re-enter right then the
parachutes came out
and they couldn't [__] find you
because all we had was binoculars
you know where is he i don't see him
anything on the starboard nothing sir
ain't nothing off the starboard right
you're [__] sitting there in the
water
clinging to a stingray
if you're lucky you landed on an island
and then you met a genie
who called your master but for some
reason you never [__] her but other
than that
that's what an astronaut was he didn't
fly in a [__] plane
you know eating spaghettios or whatever
the [__] they did and then land and get
towed to the gate by a [__] toyota
tundra
all right that's not an astronaut to me
that's a very
impressive pilot i'm very impressed
he went a lot higher than the jumbo jet
i flew to syracusan
hats off to you sir
um i just heard johnny mathis in the car
in the car [__] guy's great
you know what the hell song was he
singing
what the [__] song was he singing
something about uh it's something in
your heart
[Music]
[__] how does it go
[__] it's right there something about
that put the jingle in your
is the song in your heart and i've got
skis tell me johnny mathis i always
picture that christmas album when he's
sitting there with this
you know his skis and sweater on you
know
oh [__] though you know you think if you
were going to bring up a [__]
something you just heard you could
remember it
um anyways i hope you guys have a very
merry christmas it is one day away have
you finished your shopping
i know the podcast is late i know it's
late you know what i actually recorded
it this morning
and i was [__] with my dog on it and
he unplugged my device
and then somehow it all got erased so
this is the second time i'm doing it
so i think because of that i think i
sound pretty jolly right about now don't
you
i'm still coughing up mold any doctors
listen to this podcast
do you well that's that's uh i don't
know if that's impressive
why would you listen to this podcast do
you need a break from thinking
huh because you're so [__] smart
because you went to college until you
were 35
and now you're [__] 900 grand in debt
and you're looking up people's [__]
really that was your game plan
you know if you wanted to [__] nurse
you you could have just had your girl
you know just put on a nurse's outfit
what's the difference
the goods are all the same did you
really need to go through all of that
just so you could walk around instead of
somebody saying you know mr johnson they
have to be like
dr johnson i like how doctors
like when they go to a [__]
restaurant they have to say you know
table four and they got to be you know
[__] you know dr
marble head why can't you say just say
four from marblehead
why'd i pick marblehead i don't know why
peterson
you know four for peterson's got four
for dr peterson
you know get over yourself you [__]
douche
so many of those the goddamn doctors do
are not involved in life and death [__]
i'm not saying they don't kill people
and i'm not i guess while you know if
they [__] up they can kill somebody
but a lot of them you know they're
looking at toes they look checking out
your ears your throat and that type of
[__]
you know that those are like the jiffy
lube doctors
you know that's all they're doing
changing the [__] air filter draining
out the oil put the blood back
in put a new filter on pour the [__]
back in the top of the engine
call me in two days that's all you're
doing all right
those real guys that deal with the
[__] the insides the pistons and all
that [__] those are the guys
you know or the computer
those are the real doctors you know
so next time you go out to a [__]
whatever the [__] it's called cracker
barrel just say your last name
all right dr peterson
you [__] douche i hope you're getting
mugged
you know i don't go to a [__]
restaurant is it the stand-up comedian
burr table for one because i'm on the
road and i'm lonely
comedian burr comedian bird table for
one
anyways did you guys watch any football
now gives a [__] about football it's
almost over can you believe how [__]
fast the nfl season goes by
why is it so short you know why because
it's a [__] man's game that's why
september october november december and
you're in the playoffs
four months baseball starts in april so
that's april may june july you just
right now we would be in the dog days of
summer with baseball
but football it's [__] it's almost
over
you know this time next month we'll be
sitting there
waiting for the uh the pro bowl
which i'm going to by the way i'm going
to be out there
with like 87 other people in that
stadium
[Laughter]
it's it's [__] do you realize this is
how much of a [__] game baseball is
or let's let's spin it positively
because it's christmas eve it's the eve
before
christmas um
this is how manly football is
baseball players if you're healthy for
the whole year
you play as many professional games as a
football player
plays in a 10-year career you know
and after a 10-year career most football
players
they have damage that they're not
walking away from they got some sort of
a limp some sort of twitch in their eye
they got voices in their head their head
doesn't [__] turn anymore they got
something their knees blown out they got
something baseball players what do they
got
huh other than abroad in every [__]
other city you'd never want to go to you
know
they got chicks in baltimore kansas city
loves both nfl cities let me think we're
[__] up
wait there's 32 teams there's more
football teams
than baseball that doesn't work out does
it whatever i'm just i'm just upset
why is it why it just goes by so [__]
fast
anyways i tell you something i gotta
tell you something right now i think
peyton manning has a good shot at tying
his younger brother
with the ring this year what do you
think about that earlier this year
you know i was like the giants of the
[__] giants you don't need to tell a
patriots fan about
the giants oh you don't need to tell us
about those cuts
all right i kept waiting for them to
turn it on
versi was freaking out in november i'm
like dude they do this every year
they pace themselves and then they start
trying
right around [__] about a week before
thanksgiving
and then they just go on a run and they
just punch everybody in the mouth eli
closes his eyes looks at the opposite
end zone and throws the ball and
sticks to somebody's helmet or [__]
drops in out of the heavens
in double coverage and the expression on
his face never changes
you know he's like the manchurian
candidate of [__] nfl players
um never seen a quarterback as good as
him
as look as stupid as he does with a
helmet on
it's like he i don't think i would look
worse with a helmet on
you know usually someone who's not
athletic like myself
when we put on athletic equipment it's
just funny we don't look cool we look
like
idiots and uh as good as eli
is he he looks like a guy he looks like
the the last guy you would pick in gym
class
anyways i'm just pissed because he beats
us every time we go to the [__] super
bowl
um but anyways the giants are out
now the 49ers i don't know what to think
about them
after that dropping last night against
seattle
and i was really rooting for the 49ers
i've always liked the 49ers well that's
not true in 81 i didn't i was a cowboys
fan
and uh but i i just you know by the end
of it i just
you know the west coast offense bill
walsh all that [__] i just love them
um and you know pete carroll drives me
nuts
i can't stand that guy i don't like that
guy because he looks like the greatest
guy
ever he looks like he just rescued a cat
out of a tree
you know after rescuing a dog from a
shelter
after uh you know i don't know saving
somebody from drowning he just looked
like he looks like a [__]
he looks like a mormon you know could
you look any more wholesome than that
he looks like he goes to church every
week and sings hymns you know
only has sex missionary style you know
only does it for procreation you know
what i mean like there's nothing [__]
wrong with the guy
yet the way he left [__] uh
usc i mean john calipari must have been
like nice
that's the way it's done there petey
that's how you do it
that right you see what he just did
that's hot
that's how it's done that's how it's
done you break every [__] rule
you [__] can you win championships
and right when you smell those
[__] coming you leave
and you let the school deal with it
right that's what the [__] he did
you know so then he's up there looking
all wholesome the worst thing about
losing to a pete carroll team
or just whenever a pete carroll team
scores a touchdown
is they're always going to cut to that
wholesome guy and you're going to catch
him reacting to the touchdown and what
does he do
does he make like a [__] war face
does he go
[__] yeah like rex ryan something manly
no he goes whoa
[Laughter]
it's genius it's [__] g it's the one
you expected like rex right [__] yeah
you expect they're gonna do that
you don't expect somebody to be like
whoa
trolla like he does everything but skip
down the [__] sidelines it makes it
even more annoying to lose to somebody
if somebody's like [__] growling like
a grizzly bear
it makes it losing a little more
acceptable
but when that whether when making noises
you'd make if you were pushing
your toddler on a swing it's uh it's
really degrading
so anyways you know seattle just in
general
is just [__] annoying it's a great
goddamn city but i don't like this
stadium
how they designed it so their fans that
aren't that loud would sound louder
i don't like that and then they get all
this credit
right well these fans are so loud no
the architect was awesome
um anyways so now i'm looking
i don't know i think green bay is still
[__] in it
i have no idea now all of a sudden it
seems up for grabs after the last couple
years i was looking at the nfc going
this is completely lopsided you know the
three top teams in the league
are in the nfc so you're gonna be
watching the super bowl in the nfc
uh championship game at the very least
and uh the afc we're just gonna show up
to get our [__] asses kicked
you know that's just been my my opinion
okay and i stand by my criticism
of my own team's [__] defense as you
saw we struggled
with the goddamn jaguars
all right and i know you know brady
threw a couple
of pics and that type of thing but but
did we made their quarterback
whatever the [__] chad henny whatever
the hell his name is
you know made that guy look like john
elway
so anyways i got a feeling uh i
got a feeling peyton manning uh he's got
a you got a [__] chance
he's got a chance and i'm somehow
rooting for the guy
i'm trying to hold up my hatred of the
guy and i just don't have it anymore
once he left the colts it just it's just
he's not on the colts anymore i don't
care
and now he's an old guy i'm an old guy
how do i not root for an old guy he's a
[__] old guy i can relate
i can relate to it um i got typing my
stupid password here
do you guys know uh here's here's
something that happened yesterday during
uh the patriots game that i was watching
this is this is how much
the game has changed wes
welcome the great wes welker
gonna be in at the very least we'll be
in the new england patriots hall of fame
all right he's got to stay healthy he
needs a couple yeah but good
probably about 4 000 more yards and he's
going to be in the pro football hall of
fame right
so i love the guy you know speedy white
guy
playing wide receiver it gives it gives
you know uncoordinated white dudes like
me hope
gives us a role model you know what i
mean
um so anyways he catches a ball
and they go wes welker just broke jerry
rice's record and immediately
my [__] ears perk up going wes welker
broke a jerry rice record
what record did he break he broke the
record
for the most games 10 or more catches in
a game
with his 18th game of having 10 or more
catches
and i was like wes welker caught 10 or
more passes
more in his career than jerry rice
you know what i think i have to go to
the pro football reference dot com
the best football website out there by
the way
stay away from espn in the nfl when
they're too [__] busy selling their
channel in their league
this is just no [__] trim the
[__] fat
so wes welker holds the record for the
most games
as a wide receiver catching 10 or more
passes
his career yards 8486
and he has played one two three four
five six
seven eight nine seasons in nine
seasons he did what jerry rice did
in 20 seasons and jerry rice
his career total for yards is 22
895. that's how the games changed
these little [__] passes which would
have been handoffs back in the day these
guys
they're they're padding their [__]
stats there's got to be an asterisk next
to that one
here's the average yards wes welker has
15 yards
his first year 10.3 10.5 10.5 11.0
9.9 that's for the year that's was his
average
per catch 9.9 yards 12.9 11.5
here's jerry rice all right where the
[__] are we
18.9 18.3 16.6
20.4 18.1
you get the point right
back in the day they [__] they slid
that [__] pig skin around the goddamn
fail they ain't doing this little
here you go [__] i throw i throw [__]
nine yard passes to my three-year-old
[__] wes welker has the goddamn
record for that [__]
[__] nine yard crack hell i'll catch
buckshot nine yards away that ain't [__]
that's what i'm saying all these [__]
records are getting broken now damn all
of dan marino's records are falling dan
marino stood in the [__] pocket he
threw the goddamn ball
in sitting there throwing these little
bitch-ass passes down the
you know there's got to be so they got
it has to be a new stat
okay there's got to be a new stat
where a handoff is a handoff and if you
throw the [__] ball it's got it
it's got to be at least 10 [__] yards
how about that
we say that we create a new name for
whatever the [__] it is when a
quarterback
drops back to pass and throws a
three-yard pass to somebody
and does that 35 times a game he just
broke
bart starts record for most completions
in a row
he just threw 26 six-yard passes in a
road
well i gotta tell you frank when uh you
do something and
you get put in the same sentence as bart
starr i mean
look you know you've accomplished
something
um i don't know i'm just a crabby old
man
don't listen to me i'm just [__]
saying that's all i'm saying give me a
[__] break
wes welker did something in nine season
that
it took jerry rice 20 seasons to do and
you're gonna tell me there's something
right about the league
there's something right about that well
maybe in your world sir
and maybe in your universe ma'am but not
mine what do you think about that well
maybe i don't give a [__] what you think
about that you ever think about that
huh there's a lot to think about in that
all right let's do a commercial here
stamps.com everybody with the holidays
almost here
literally almost here you don't have
time to go to the post office
what do they mean but the holidays
almost here christmas what about kwanzaa
what about hanukkah you know
have those come and gone already i don't
know let's stick to the copy here with
the holidays almost here
granted they gave me this three weeks
ago you don't have time to go to the
post office traffic
parking obese people
um it will be packed with everyone
mailing holiday gifts and packages
so so do what i do oh
jesus this is the worst read ever so do
what i do use stamps.com instead
because god knows i'm too stupid to read
out loud so thank god they came up with
this wonderful system
what is stance.com you asked with
stamps.com you can avoid that
all the hassle of going to the post
office during the busy holiday season
everything you would do with the post
office you can do right from your desk
buy and print official us postage using
your own computer and printer
print postage for any letter or package
the instant you need it
then the mailman picks it up that's it
that's all it is
so easy so convenient what else do you
need
they're doing everything but bringing
you a sandwich i use stamps.com to send
out all my dvds for all my rogue gigs
i absolutely love it um you should get
you should try it too i actually got to
get a new scale i've used it so much i
broke it
well actually i dropped something on it
the other day so i gotta i gotta get a
new scale
um special offer right now get this
special offer when you use my last name
bur b-u-r-r
for a no-risk trial plus a hundred and
ten dollar bonus that includes a digital
scale that i just broke
and up to dollars free postage they
giving you 55 bucks
during the holiday season come on what
more do you want don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur
b-u-r-r that's stamps.com enter
burr all right
oh this mold this mold won't leave me
alone
so i um i know what you're thinking
well bill next time you go to a
restaurant
rather than being insecure about the
doctor
the doctor party of four why don't you
[__] waddle up to him and ask him
about you know is it okay to smoke a
moldy cigar once in your life
everyone the guy at the cigar told me
said he said i'd be fine
you know that's how a guy goes to the
doctor
he talks to some guy he doesn't know who
isn't a doctor
vaguely describes what he did and goes
do you think i'll be all right you know
the guy goes yeah yeah i think yeah i
think he'll be good
and you're like all right and then your
girl gets on you why don't you go to the
doctor
because i talked to that [__] guy
over there the guy emptying out the
trash
hey sweetheart you don't make fun of
what a guy does for a living okay
it's an unwritten rule it's an unwritten
rule now you look it down on the ground
as we walk back to the car and you don't
say good night to nobody
pope greenwich village thank you i
avoided the not having a thumb
part um all right so what what went on
in the world this week i had an awesome
week
i did another episode of glee
nudge nudge wink wink and could not have
had more fun
i will let you know when it comes out um
and that was my last work for this year
and i ain't doing [__] baby i ain't
doing anything
i recorded the podcast earlier today and
like i said i was [__] with my dog
and uh during the podcast wrestling with
her and stuff it was
funny as hell but got a little too rough
and unplugged my thing here and
the recorder and i lost that podcast
and i um still i still think about it
sometimes no
so anyways i had to make a [__] pie
today made an apple pie
and uh there's a little collateral
damage with the crust on top
made it from scratch [__] okay
so i know i come off like i'm miserable
and i'm cynical but i like johnny mathis
christmas music and i can make a pie
from scratch
you know what are you doing today i
don't want to get old john lennon on you
and so this is christmas
then what have you done um
i got it down the big [__] thing
about making a
a pie crust you can't be intimidated by
the flower
that's the thing i finally realized i
was approaching it like a [__]
every year i was like oh and then i'd
[__] it up
this year i was like i don't give a [__]
i got a whole bag of flour
you know like a pimp that has a whole
stable a horse
just sitting there like all right lady
you either make this [__] work or
i'll get another one in here to replace
you
that was the thing so i'm out in the
kitchen right and when you bake
you know aside from you know risking
getting gay bashed in your own kitchen
when you bake as a male uh you gotta
give you got to put an apron on because
your hands are gonna get all sticky so
uh believe it or not i don't own an
apron
and the only apron in the house is the
one my mother got for nia
and i swear to god it's like this floral
platter pattern
frilly [__] thing
like if an old lady had it on you'd be
like oh my god that's the greatest
grandmother ever
so i got this [__] thing on you know
me is in the [__] living room so i'm
in the kitchen i got the door closed and
she knows i'm making a pie and she
starts to smell the philly
and uh i do that food network [__]
where i don't measure the [__] out as i
as as i
you know as i'm making it you know i
have it i measure the [__] out and i put
it on these little
[__] things so i can just bam bam bam
like i'm on a shelf you know you put the
cream in
then you add the sugar whisk that
together now a little bit of salt a
little bit of nutmeg little cinnamon you
know
bam bam bam bam bam the whole [__]
thing goes
whatever your hands get all [__]
sticky so i'm sitting there right
and i'm peeling the apples and that type
of [__] i go to pick up one
and it [__] the apple falls and it
lands on two of my little things that
already have measured out
and they tip over on the counter and
then the apple [__] lands on the
floor and rolls across the kitchen
now nia always gets on me for my temper
flipping out and causing tension
and i realized that okay so when i
flipped out rather than screaming
i sort of crouched down
and i just went
something like that with this [__]
apron on
so nia heard that you know she
it wasn't loud but the intensity was
[__] ridiculous
so she comes bursting in to make sure
i'm all right
and she's like she's like billy you okay
and i came in i got yeah yeah i'm fine
and then she's standing in that apron it
might have been the hardest i think i
ever heard her laugh
i knew i'd look a little stupid but like
she almost [__] passed out
she like laughed i think for five
minutes straight and every time she
started to stop she started going again
you know when someone is laughing so
hard you start laughing
it was one of those deals and i'm
sitting there trying to peel the apples
and she's laughing so hard i got like
[__] tears in my eyes and i can't i
can't see what i'm doing
um but long story short long story short
i just re-measured the [__]
lost a little nutmeg or whatever and um
i cooked it it had a little collateral
damage with the [__] dough on the uh
the one on top but i gotta tell you it's
nice it's a good looking [__] pie
to the point i'm gonna i'm gonna post it
and i'll tell you
as far as looks i give it a six i give
it a six
now i know once it gets posted to the
internet and all you miserable [__]
who aren't happy with your lives rather
be like being like you know what
that's not too bad that's not too bad a
job i know you guys are just gonna
[__] you know
you're gonna tear it to shreds you know
when i say i say god bless you
i say happy holidays to you too i'm
sorry
that your life i'm sorry you didn't get
that fire engine
under the christmas tree and rather than
looking at your parents
or your girlfriend whatever the [__] you
got who didn't get you that fire engine
you're gonna decide to take it out on me
and my innocent little pie
all right i hope you feel good about
yourself
um what else what else we gonna talk
about
oh i know a buddy of mine uh
you know the one who was questioning my
loyalty to the patriots because i had
the audacity to say that their defense
stinks
uh actually he called me after the
jaguars game and said i
i think i agree with you now um
and then he also he left the message he
asked me if i saw the uh the nra
press conference you know or as he said
the nr
doge you see the [__] nra um
uh press conference [__] what is this
mold gonna be out of my system
according to the guy at the cigar store
i'll be fine um
as he sells me another cigar um what the
hell was i talking about yeah so yeah he
said dude you to check out this nra
thing he goes it's like and he said to
me he goes
and you know me dude i'm in the middle
and i know a million people who say i'm
in the middle and they're not in the
middle
i've said i'm in the middle i'm not in
the middle i lean to the left
with a nice [__] uppercut or right
that's where i am
you know i am to the left
when it comes to the working man
when it comes to the twinkle toes
when it comes to you know people wanting
to come to the country i'm to the left
you know when it comes to other [__]
like taking responsibility for your
[__] actions i'm on the right
no it isn't okay you're a douche go [__]
yourself go make it right
or go sit in that cell and and pay your
dues
you don't get a do-over it all depends
but i'm mainly bailey on the right
i'm one of the angriest liberals you'll
ever [__] meet
i guess i'm supposed to be doing yoga or
something i i miss i missed something
out
on the on the pamphlet or what i don't
know what the [__] it is but this guy
you know i got a i got a bunch of people
that like verzi's another guy he's one
of those guys the classic guy who says
he's in the middle
you know dude you're not you lean this
way you totally every [__]
issue i bring up you lean this way and
then they always say the same thing dude
i'm
registered independent
it's the dumbest thing ever give a [__]
what you're registered
that's a classic thing you you register
independent and then argue all one side
and then when people just accuse you
yeah yeah you're [__]
liberal you're a conservative and they
go i'm a registered independent
well you didn't have to pass a test
you know you just you just
defined yourself as an independent
the same way madison square garden just
gives itself the nickname
the world's most famous arena
you know and then everybody just uh it's
the world's most there it is
there's the world's most famous arena a
cookie cutter [__] stadium
a stadium that an arena that was made
during the worst
most uncreative time of arenas
the world's most famous arena if you can
tell me how that thing looks
more different than any other stadium
during that [__] time then god damn
it i'll make you an apple pie
what do you think about that um
so anyways he goes uh
yes all you people out there who who
think just because you're
uh you're a registered independent
and then therefore you can just argue
the same side of every [__]
argument and still you know and then
that's your parachute
i'm a registered independent you know my
best friend's black
you know it's like one of those deals
it's your little get out of jail
[__] [__] thing all right i'm i'm
here to tell you you're not fooling
anybody
all right you're full of [__] but this
guy he actually
i've known him for 20 years and i really
don't know how he feels about anything
keeps the [__] real close to the vest
and uh he always surprises me
every time i think he's going this way
i'll go that way i mean i don't know he
might be a contrarian i have no [__]
idea he might just be arguing the
opposite side just to [__] drive me
nuts
but anyways he says check out this nra
thing
he goes uh he goes you know i don't
really feel one way or
another about it but these guys they
come off
like it's a [__] cartoon like their
solution
to uh the gun situation is more guns
that's what he tells me so i sit down
and i go i gotta [__] watch this [__]
get some material out of this right and
uh
i put it on and i watched it and i gotta
admit i thought the guy made a lot of
good points
i don't know if i'm gonna get hate mail
over this i don't i mean i don't have a
problem if they ban
you know semiotic semi-automatic uh
[__] assault weapons
i don't know what you need one of those
for
you know if you're using it to hunt
you're [__] cheating
like how bad a shot are you that you got
a bang bang bang bang bang
got it you know
so i don't have a problem with that but
like i don't like the whole demonizing
of people who own guns that you're just
automatically evil
it's stupid that would be like
demonizing me i use a computer so
therefore
uh you know i advocate uh
sexual predators or people who steal
your identity you know what i mean
i mean i kind of think if you're in the
nra
you got your gun legally and i think i i
would with no stats whatsoever
completely over my head no research no
nothing i'm willing to bet
all right a meringue pie
it's all gonna be pies this week dad i
would say like night what 99
of the people who register a gun legally
first of all probably never do anything
most of them probably never do anything
more
than go down to the [__] gun range
and shoot it then you got another
percentage that actually go out and they
go shoot a pheasant
or a quail or an elk or some [__]
like that right
but the amount that actually go out and
commit a [__] crime or shoot somebody
or something i i wouldn't you know
the problem you know what the [__]
problem is is
we don't have a way of weeding out
sociopaths psychos
maniacs there's no way to find them
that's what you need to do
if you could do that if you could
somehow [__] do that
you wouldn't even need metal detectors
at the airport
you wouldn't need anything there could
be a gun in every [__] house no one's
ever gonna go out and deliberately do
something somebody could you know
obviously have an accident
but [__] you have accidents in cars
people put pools in their backyards
people [__] break their necks [__]
happens people fall off ladders
[__] [__] happens there's got to be a
way you know
if i was running [__] i would
you know when you're like on a [__]
tangent you realize halfway through how
dumb you sound that was just the moment
right there i was like if i was running
[__]
[Laughter]
yet you listen because you're laughing
at me aren't you well go [__] yourselves
i don't care
i'm feeling good i made a pie today
and what have you done um
if i was running [__] i would go to the
people who came up with that black light
that helps you find jizz on a quilt you
know
and be like make one of those lights for
psychos
you know and then i would replace all
the lights in in the street lights
you know with that light which would
create
jobs you know
and then with the surplus of that money
we'd have health care
uh just stay with me on this one and
it'll be like this maniac light
and if you're good [__] you have a soul
and you have a [__] hat and you're
not a [__]
it would be this one particular color
see nobody would know about this [__] be
all top secret it'd just be
i'd know about it the guys who invented
it and all
the million people who had to unscrew
the old light bulbs and put no you don't
have to tell them
just tell them it's some new energy
efficient thing and you just weed out
all the psychos
and i know what all the liberals are
going to say and then what do you do
with them do you kill them if you kill
them then you're just as bad as they are
all right well then i'll go classic
right wing we take them we stick them on
a [__] island
let them all kill each other now that
would be a dumb thing now that would be
stupid
that would be a dumb [__] liberal way
of doing things we can't kill these
people we can't
illegally detain them because they
haven't done anything yet
aka that and then you stick them on an
island
and then you create this can you dig it
[__] island
you know god help us when those [__]
get organized and i'll come back ashore
all right there's not enough will
smith's tom cruises and [__]
i don't know what not give me another
action hero chuck norris is out there to
stop that level of evil
that's the thing you gotta um
like those [__] people holding up
signs saying that the nra is killing
children um
it's just first of all they weaken that
side of the argument
because they're coming off like complete
psychopaths
you know i don't know i found the press
really annoying too like they had
already made up their minds
like they were all over taking pictures
of the people holding up the the
protesting things
and some one of the press guys i'm
assuming suppressed guy i don't know who
it was but he's in the room
you know assuming it's got to be
somebody from the press
yells at the nra guy and he goes uh what
do you think about the protesters
and the nra guy doesn't say anything
just continues with his speech
and then the same guy in the crowd goes
uh
he goes he goes oh stick with the script
it's like dude are you a are you still a
reporter at that point
because you don't sound like one your
job's to go down there and report what
happened
i'm fine with what do you think about
the protesters
even then that was borderline because
the guy was still in the middle of his
statement but
but that's okay because it did happen
but when the guy chooses no comment
that's what you report
no comment he goes on to heckle stick
with the script
i don't know that's a [__] idiots man
it's they're just i i don't there is no
[__] solution
until you can come up with something as
much as i was making a joke about having
a
psycho street light that identifies
maniacs
until you do that i don't give a [__]
you know there's still going to be going
to be problems isn't there
jesus christ look what those [__]
maniacs do in the middle east they don't
even use guns
they go down to the home depot they get
a [__] thing of fertilizer
right whatever the [__] they do when
they walk into a food court
and blow themselves up then what are
they gonna do
close down the hardware stores all right
i'm going over my head
uh so this is christmas
all right this is cruising along 43
minutes in hey everybody
did you enjoy the podcast this year as
much as i did well i sure hope you did
um oh they also blame video games
blaming video games which um
i don't know i don't know what to tell
you i find
violent video games to be uh
stress relieving i also find going to a
gun range and shooting a gun
to be oddly calming the same sort of
calm i get when i make a [__] apple
pie
i'm not even lying to you i i get that
same level of enjoyment
because i'm not a psycho i'm a [__] i'm
a dick
i'm a [__]
but i'm not a psycho all right i'll
stand you you come up with that light
i'll [__] stand underneath it
all you're going to see is a bald spot
in a beautiful soul
all right plowing ahead here by the way
people i got
i got a couple of gigs coming up in 2013
um in january i'm going to be at
flappa's
flappers comedy club in burbank
california absolutely love this club
and uh i'm hoping to have a couple of uh
up and coming heavy hitters opening for
me i haven't reached out to anybody yet
but um
flap is in burbank
and uh that's going to be on january
10th
two shows we'll give you the links and
everything if you go to the podcast page
on billboard.com
and then on november 26th i am gonna be
out in honolulu hawaii
at the uh hookie lau [__] what the
[__] the name of the goddamn things
i'm the worst
see why do i why do i talk myself into
these damn corners
well because you're not organized bill
you know
you don't have any sort of you know
set list just oh [__] yourself um
i thought it was gonna be up on my
website where the [__] is it
whatever just look you do the work
look up bill burr and [__] hawaii and
you'll see it
it's january 26th i will be there and
uh and i'm going to the pro bowl
you won't be able to miss me it'll be me
and [__] 83 other people in hawaiian
shirts
it's going to be awesome and then i'm at
the wilbur theater boston massachusetts
my old stomping grounds where i
started wilbur theater right across from
nick's comedy stop
where i started march 2nd 1992 on an
open mic
night long long time ago uh wilbur
theater february 21st
two shows and february 22nd one show
and other than that the only other thing
i have that's on sale right now
is may 30th in baltimore maryland
i'm at the maryhof symphony hall
doesn't that sound amazing you know how
loud i'm going to be it's a symphony
hall
i'll sound like a [__] seahawk fan
it's all that artificial help
um all right back to the podcast here
so let's answer some questions here
uh if you'd like to email me it's uh
uh what the [__] is it i think it's bill
at the mmpodcast.com
we'll have that link up there too i
haven't said it in so long i forget what
the [__] it is
um all right this is terrible whatever
you guys are gonna be working today are
you
you know aren't you home putting on a
sweater
uh questions from new zealand
so you know what's great about new
zealand i was at a christmas party last
night and i met some woman
there and uh she was saying how in world
war one
that when great britain declared war in
germany
that new zealand felt because they were
their colony
both them in australia they had to
follow suit
so they told england that hey we're
right there with you and you know what
england did did they mix them in with
their troops
no you ever see that all quiet on the
western front that trench warfare we had
gas masks because using poisonous gas
wasn't considered illegal
in war mustard gas and all that [__]
hand-to-hand
fighting [__] in a [__] hole
some of the worst conditions ever that's
where they were sent
all those people up there they were all
from [__] new zealand and australia
not one
english man had the [__] balls
to go there in the trenches at least
this is the way a person
from new zealand explained it to me i
might have exaggerated a little bit but
i'm also trying to get some emails here
not one englishman had the balls didn't
have the [__] balls
they were all sitting there with winston
churchill holding hands
you know having a biscuit um
no but sir listen this [__] the total
number of new zealand troops
and nurses to serve overseas in 1914 and
um was 140 100 444 from a population of
just over a million
10 percent of their over 10 percent are
roughly 10
of their population fought in the war 42
percent of the men
of military age served 16
697 new zealanders were killed of course
they were they sent them right to the
front
and 41 317 were wounded during the war
a 58 casualty rate
you know this is the kind of [__]
england does and then i go over there
and they start giving me [__] about
george bush you know it's like why don't
you [__] clear off your register
there
ian before you come in and make i can't
remember the last time somebody from
england gave me [__] about the foreign
policy i just like [__] pissing them
off
because then they keep listening and
then the next time i play the leicester
square theater hopefully they'll be
there
then maybe they yell some [__] out we
have a good time
all right question from new zealand um
i live in christchurch new zealand oh
jesus
christ church all one word
i live in christ church new zealand by
the way i'm going to midnight mass
tonight with nia's mom
oh boy with the [__] choir
keep in mind that jesus christ
two years ago we had an earthquake in
new zealand i didn't hear about that
then again i don't pay attention to [__]
two years ago we had an earthquake which
wrecked the city and killed a couple
hundred people
and almost killed me too now for three
years i've been going out with a great
girl
she's nice smart caring fun to hang out
with and i'm not sick of banging her
problem is her cousin got killed in the
earthquake oh sorry to hear that
and ever since then she's been terrified
the aftershocks have all but stopped now
but she hasn't recovered
every time a truck buys drives past on
the road outside my house
she flinches and trembles sometimes she
cries
randomly she won't move away from the
city
because all of her family is here and
i'm pretty much at the end of my rope
aside aside from this she might be even
marriage material but i just can't deal
with this anymore
on the day of the quake i was within 20
feet of being squashed like a grape by a
four-story building that fell on the
sidewalk
i just been walking on while she was
having lunch in a park
so i can't sympathize with her mental
fragility anymore it's been too long
with no improvement
um i don't even know how the [__] i
expect you to help me
i guess i just want to complain without
anyone i know in real life calling me an
[__] for it because the perception in
my social circle
is that i have to just deal with it but
i'm not sure i can do it for another two
years
anyway that's my problem any advice
would be appreciated come and do a show
in new zealand sometimes because this is
a great country for a taurus and i can't
be bothered going to the states to see
you
and aside from that enjoy what might be
the longest range go [__] yourself for
the week
cheers mate take care um
well as mean as you sound i totally
relate to that
and you kind of sound like a little bit
of a walled off psycho which i also
relate to
so you're probably you know despite the
fact the building almost fell on you
which is kind of a stretch
i consider a building almost fell on you
like it starts to fall and you run out
of the way
not that i was just there 20 minutes ago
yeah you and a thousand other [__]
people
all right um but anyways
yeah i totally get we you know i get it
i get it two years of every time a truck
goes
by she starts shaking her
doing that yeah [__] driving nuts
after a while at some point you got to
grow up and get over it
you know it's like living with the
[__] chihuahua
sitting there with his eyes all bugged
out shaking and peeing in the [__]
corner at some point
you know you got to grow a dick have you
asked her to go to
have you asked her to go to therapy
maybe you should do that that's what nia
suggested when she did she did the first
podcast that i lost
uh she's not available now she's
unavailable
um she suggested that you um
ask her to go to therapy just sit down
and say listen i'm concerned
with the fact that you're still this
traumatized by the earthquake and i want
to help you get some help
and start with that and if she doesn't
get help and she keeps shaking
and trembling in the corner and peeing
like a little yorkshire terrier
um i don't know dude
you either gotta break up with her or
you gotta lay off the booze because
something's gonna
something's gonna you're gonna snap
at some point she's going to be like
you're going to be a little drunk
and you could you've had a bad day
you're having a couple you're throwing
them down they'll [__] shoot right
and all of a sudden
whatever happens somebody blows their
nose next door and she's
doing that [__] and you're going to be
like you're going to look at her and
imitate her
and then and that's going to [__]
destroy her you're going to do that
jesus that just sounded creepy when i
did that but it's going to happen
so i try to get her helper i would get
out of the [__] relationship
you know i mean it's been two [__]
years
it's been two [__] years okay and uh
you know she's acting like it happened
two weeks ago
yeah two years that's that's plenty of
[__] time
to get i mean you never get over losing
somebody
but like to still have it be that
[__] raw that you know somebody can't
even break wind without you you
breaking down crying is is uh
you know i mean maybe she's that
sensitive and if she's that [__]
sensitive and you're not i don't know
sometimes opposite attract but i don't
think it is in this case uh
that's it all right 24 year old virgin
on first date
hello bill and possibly nia sorry
she's not here this week she was
during the first taping i'm sorry um as
should be deduced
by the subject line i'm a major [__]
i've had absolutely zero romantic
experiences in my life
i took some pretty brutal rejections
when i was in high school and have been
too timid to try my luck since
it's not like i'm a cowering blubbering
mess when i'm talking to women either
i just think tend to think why bother i
know what she's going to say
it's a loser mentality which is stupid i
know
so what do you need my help for sir you
know you're being a [__] and you know
you're
you're psyching yourself out you know
what's going on
huh you know what the deal is
all right let's keep reading uh by now
there's this girl who's really
interested in me
i'm not used to that feeling ah
come on dude what the [__] is wrong with
you
right now there's a girl that's injured
me and i'm not used to that what are you
a [__] cyclops
you can't believe the kind of guys that
women are interested in
they're not just about looks you know
they're about senses of humor uh
money sorry i know they like other [__]
um we met in an english course she's
attractive way smarter than me and funny
as [__]
we have a lot in common and she's almost
as single cynical and blackhearted as i
am she's perfect
she's got a lot of issues though within
the within minutes of the first time we
talked she started telling me about how
she cuts herself
oh jesus and about how often she tries
to kill herself all right right there
dude it's over
right there it's over okay
and he goes on to say she's bipolar and
schizophrenic
all right guys if you're gonna make up
emails can you try to do a better job
and not make them this [__] over the
top
dude you use deduced in the first
[__] sentence of your email and
you're too [__] dumb to not know
to get away from this if this is true
i'll play along whatever it's christmas
i'll play along let's just act like this
is true she's bipolar and schizophrenic
oh that's great she cuts herself tries
to kill herself she's bipolar she's
schizophrenic
you know i think i think it's all there
bipolar and schizophrenic that's like
the two-piece meal at kentucky fried
chicken
with the side of cutting yourself in a
to-go
big gulp of suicide there you go that's
what you want to let in your inner
circle
she's told me that she's she has a slew
of characters that talk to her which she
uh go
[__] yourself all right nice try buddy
okay i'm done with this email
all right introspective drugs hey bill
love the podcast
and i've got gotten a lot of my friends
to listen to you in the last few months
i'm a 49ers fan i love hearing patriots
fans [__]
when they get beat well you don't hear
that a lot do you
huh let me ask you a question are you
good at catching punts
you want to play that game sir huh
haven't won anything in 20 [__] years
how'd you like that seattle beat down
you know what here's my pete carroll
impression for you how many times did
you see this last night
that sounds too much like ric flair i
gotta get some nfl films audio of what
he sounds like when he said when he does
that
anyways he goes i know you hang out with
joe rogan and a lot of famous la
comedians
and i'm curious if you ever are willing
to get down with mushrooms or any kind
of psychedelic substance
um get down with it get down
um not like today or next week just any
time in the rest of your life
you seem like the kind of guy who would
be balls out laughing making everybody
else laugh with introspective insights
oh there's no doubt i would have a great
[__] time if i ever did it but that's
that's really what scares me you know
what i mean
like when i listen to people who've done
mushrooms i listen to it it sounds
[__] awesome
it does but uh you know
there's a price that you pay when you do
[__] like that
see i like being ignorant you know what
i mean
like walking into nature sober is is
awesome to me
because i don't know that if i was on
mushrooms
that i i would be enjoying a tree that
much more
the fact that i never did it like you
know
like the first time you get high
if you shoot up with heroin like those
guys chase that every [__] day no
matter what they do
see that patriots game wasn't that
unbelievable
compared to what you know once you've
shot up it's it's
it's only so [__] enjoyable so
drugs scare me because i know that i
would really enjoy them
and i've seen what they've done to a lot
of people's lives
and um and i'm not literally saying you
end up on the street homeless i'm not
talking about that extreme thing i'm
just saying
how i've seen a lot of people waste
a lot of time and talent and potential
and all that type of stuff
but um i do not question why people do
them at all
you know i would love to hallucinate you
know
i'd love to talk to a sneaker why
wouldn't you
talk to everything else that can talk at
this point i might you know
be a new experience but the problem is i
just feel like i would i
i would love it and uh you know
that's why i don't do it anyways there's
a lot of comedians talk about
weak topical [__] but it seems like you
have a deep vein of intelligence
that a certain audience hones in on oh
i get it i see what you're buttering me
up and you want to do mushrooms with me
this elizabeth you're treating me like
an 18 year old incoming freshman
you know you're the most beautiful girl
here you're not like
the others no dude i'm i'm
i'm not saying i never would but like i
just i i'm not going
i i know myself too well the [__] i do
with alcohol isn't that enough
enough of a [__] sign you know i'm
going to be buzzed tonight when i go to
church
that's just i can't i can't show up near
his mom there was booze on my breath
i wasn't raised like that you know when
i tell you once that guy breaks open the
wine
all bits all bets are off underrated a
flask
flask at midnight mass you know what's
the great thing about a flask
is if somebody catches you with it oh
yeah all you do to get out of it is you
you look at them you do that nod and you
give them a little toast
and it's just so awkward they have to
nod and kind of give you like a [__]
black power fist back to you what are
they going to do
you know anyways girlfriend jealous of
dog dearest
william i watched your stand-up special
my girlfriend and we loved it oh thank
you very much
um anyways my girlfriend is jealous of
my dog
the dog is small and i have often have
it
laying with me on the couch sleeping in
bed with us
um of course i'm cuddling with my
girlfriend at the same time
while you cuddle with a beast i know
it's a little dog but still
you know so you got like you got a
little threesome going on there i kind
of see
how why she would be annoyed but she
still complains
that i'm more affectionate with the dog
and is often
mean and abusive to the dog pushing her
around calling her [__]
slash [__] etc
has this happen to you am i out of my
mind or is it
strange for a girl to be jealous of an
animal
all right dude here's the thing um
you need to stop sleeping with your dog
when your girlfriend's there you got to
know that humans are higher up than dogs
okay treat your girl with a little more
respect okay
first off and secondly you need to dump
that woman
okay that whole [__] there like
getting jealous of the dog is one thing
he's not jealous of the dog she's just
upset
that you're probably saying way more
lovey-dovey things to the [__] dog
and are way more affectionate to the
[__] dog
caressing the dog petting it way more
than you are her so that's normal but
when she takes it to the point
of the bizarre calling the dog a [__] or
a [__]
and then hitting an animal pushing
around on any [__] level that's
that's a done deal right there
all right if those street lights were
there i don't know what color she would
come out but it wouldn't be the color
that i
am all right all american here
apple pie and chevrolet [__] chevrolet i
like fords but you know what i'm saying
that's what you got to do you got to
curb your attention you're giving to
your dog and you got to dump that woman
that's it anyone who's mean to a [__]
animal is uh they're a piece of [__] and
that's the tip of the iceberg
it's the bronx tale lock the door test
right there you're out see ya
all right overrated underrated uh bill i
love the podcast and listen to it all
the time i think there are way too many
overrated sports cliches
for example give 110 percent
taking one game at a time at the end of
the day
etc any halftime interview with any
coach
what do you think bill what's your
opinion on sports cliches
are they overrated or underrated if so
what are some of your favorite
slash most annoying ones
um all right well this time of year they
always have the classic
i'll tell you they're the eight and six
team nobody wants to play
they got that one um
they always have that team the best team
with the shitty record that nobody
wants to play um
the the one that the the coach will say
i'll tell you you give me 22 of those
guys
give me 22 of those guys and i go
undefeated
uh they don't make them like that guy
he's a throwback that guy's a throwback
the lovely near everybody just walked in
you walked in later already went by the
whole thing
um what are some of the other ones
oh i this is the one i hate the most
i'll tell you you hate that guy but if
he played for you you'd love him
they always say that about those dirty
pieces of [__] that go and like
deliberately blow somebody's knee out
and end their career
and for the record i wouldn't love them
if they played for my team
i wouldn't i don't like dirty pieces of
[__] whether they're wearing
the uniform of the team that i love or
or that i hate i don't like those guys
so
um i don't know if that's an overrated
underrated
but i gave you overrated underrated
underrated uh bringing a flask
to midnight mass is underrated
and uh hey nia come over we only got one
mic come over here for a second
all i need is one mic how was uh how'd
that pie look
that pie looked amazing it was i walked
in and i was like
it was beautiful you did a great job and
how manly did i look in that apron
i don't understand why you won't allow
me to tweet pictures like this well i
think because i get in because i get
enough [__]
why help him out yeah i laughed for
a solid five minutes on that one that
was that was good it was great but that
pie looks amazing i can't wait to have
it tomorrow
all right so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna i'm gonna [__] send out the
picture
of the pie yeah and watch they'll [__]
all over that they'll [__] all over it
the edge of pie did you already throw it
in somebody's face
somebody take your [__] on it [__] do
they know what a gourmet cook you are
though have you talked about that
how you really your skills in the
kitchen have become
quite good thank you that was that was
that was
damn near a compliment well it is a
compliment and you made that that prime
no the braised short ribs which was
amazing braised short ribs he made
braised short ribs about this beautiful
bottle of wine it was very
romantic it was still it was delicious
too it was like restaurant quality
good yeah overrated cooking it's not
that hard
all these [__] jackasses on the food
network and this is blah blah blah this
is going to infuse and that's
well but it takes a certain amount of
creativity i think you know
to like make something really special
anyone can make a buy the book recipe
but you gotta add your own little you
know
that's all i'm doing
they own what don't ever don't ever do
that again
no i just follow the recipe word for
[__] word wow
that's it when you get more when you get
more confident you'll be able to
improvise a little bit more and you
won't have to do that you'll just be
like i'm making this today and you'll be
well i seem insecure when i'm in the
kitchen i'm sitting there wearing a
woman's [__]
apron you are you you were wearing my
apron
yeah that your mom gave me so it was
kind of like
well either way i laughed
yes you did all right well merry
christmas nia
and merry christmas happy hanukkah happy
kwanzaa
merry christmas everybody to everybody
and thank you everybody this year
everybody coming out to my
shows everybody who's listened anybody
who's advertised on this podcast
podcast god bless you god bless you
go [__] yourselves we got one more
monday
left in this year i hope you guys have a
good time don't uh i know there's gonna
be some douchebags
at christmas and in law it's just
somebody you don't [__] like and uh
just whatever don't don't engage
for the sake of your mom your dad or
just everybody enjoy even the person
you're with
just don't get involved in it all right
just i don't know
i don't have to go stand under the
street light see what color they are
all right that's it go [__] yourselves
[Applause]
[Music]
so
you